hi guys how you doin I do really enjoy
this today's I feel like I'm in a really
special support group like hi I'm marina
and I am data scientist hi I understand
you cool and I'm working for grey cortex
we are doing cybersecurity there and
this is really like trying to make what
a safer place and cybersecurity is like
playing cat and mouse and like a story
is never ending story as machine
learning tools becomes more popular
because more available hackers tool
becomes more sophisticated and that's
why we have to use more and more complex
model to detect it and to predict these
actions and so on and what I have
realized that making word the safer
place it's not a rocket science it's a
data science and what we're doing as a
scientist I'm curious and I like asking
questions and finding an answer and
first question was what is actually so
complicated about cyber security as a
application for machinery and tasks and
in this section we will discuss of
course data models and some special
requirements which coming from these
fields of application and after that we
will go to the most interesting part
which is how to build machine learning
spaceship for detect more old and
persistent security attack like psycho
injection and after that we will talk a
few words about how to make this model
actually fly how to deploy this model
how to make it work in the real world so
let's start what is so complicated about
cybersecurity first thing of course it's
data we analyze we get data from the
network traffic which means that data is
a semi-structured it goes in sequences
and it can this sequences contains value
of different types and it's really
specific because each network protocol
used on each its own data structure its
own specific information and we need to
capture data parsed it and structured
before we can do any analysis on it and
second thing I would like to mention
today it's labels if you want to use
some supervised model you usually need
to label data first so you need to
understand which is actually attack and
which is normal behavior no normal data
that goes with some complex think about
this because you need here we go have an
odd next question where to get this
attack samples nowadays happily exists
pretty much - so like penetration
testing tools and honey pots and
whatever that we can useful for this
task but with supervised models often
the problem is unbalanced data because
for trained supervised model you usually
need to train and set
about equals with number of positive
sets and negative data and you can think
that getting these attack samples it's
more complex complicated part of this
but actually sometimes given benign said
is more complex task because if you
think about it how many actually unique
requests to a single application can use
and not that much actually and to solve
this problem we use data generation and
extrapolation tools okay and next thing
it's well known problem of machine
learning model that it's pretty lazy so
it could get more obvious let's say
information from from the from the
entire data well I mean for example if
you would would like to train your cat
or dog classifier and use mostly white
cats images for training and black dogs
for example most likely your algorithm
will fail failed was trying to detect
white dog because most likely you
already didn't decided ok it's white so
it's cat because I mostly seen white
heads but what would happen if you will
decide to detect for example red cat I
don't know this problem goes with
understanding that as a data
distribution change the accuracy of
algorithm also goes down because of this
problem that's why we use actually
trying to transfer learner right but if
for
text processing for example or for
images we have 22 2001 dataset to deal
with this change more than whatever no
one really wants to share their own
private network data it's kind of
problem for us ok and now let's go to
the method that we use it's clearly goes
from the everywhere information that we
have so if you know what to find we
normally use classification and if but
it's not really useful in real life now
because if we know how attacks looks ok
good but hackers are really creative in
in this in creating new tools new
attacks and whatever so we need to be
able to detect something that we have
never seen before and that comes with
tasks like animal detection and here at
the next question when the anomaly is an
anomaly actually look at this nice
picture one of these guys definitely not
like others but who if you look to this
tall guy on the left
I mean this he definitely looks like an
outlier if you decided if you look at it
like in time series data it's definitely
like a spike and maybe this this is
animal this kitten anomaly but
definitely he is an animal like in
internment of content analysis but
actually attacker this mirka because he
has a flash stick in the pocket ok
animal detection actually works pretty
well for security application but you
need to be really careful during train
in this model
to not train the some some attacks as a
normal behavior
as a normal actions that's why we use
the combination of supervised and
unsupervised and semi-supervised
learning to get the good product so our
solution it's holistic combination of
different models like prediction
analysis flow analysis and rule-based
and so on everything is connected to
everything and we input network data to
this and after purchasing and analyzing
we get network visibility security
events Network statistics and the risks
and next think about cybersecurity is a
speed for example for one gigabit canal
Channel sorry
we have about more ok about 1 million
1/2 packet per second to analyze and
users don't really want to wait a
minutes while your model get that
prediction because user want to just
click link and get the result
immediately and as you've seen before
analysis tools really combination of
models so during the development one
single detector you need to keep in mind
that it will be part of bigger system
and so you need to use computation
research really wisely and next thing
last thing yes
it's false alerts it's really headache
since its reduced trust to your security
tool in general because if your if your
application skills application arise
to allure to often and well where it's
nothing serious actually users start to
ignore it and it's caused a problem when
it's real some some some malicious
action so now we have a big picture how
it goes in cybersecurity
we know that it goes from the special
requirements from performance for models
from data and it's really sensitive for
false alert congratulations
now we can move to the next section and
see how actually develop the model first
what is actually a sequel injection in
fire 1998 Jeff first off find out found
out that putting special commands to
sequel to the query may force server
reveal information stored on it and as a
good guy he reported to Microsoft about
this problem but Microsoft said that
it's nothing to worry about it so no one
will use it and you should just forget
about it but hacker said mmm sequel
injection and how it actually works for
example you would like to log into some
web page and you just put your user name
and password to log in form and it will
be present in query like that
application server will transform it to
the database request like that and after
identification post you will get your
data as a HTTP content now let's suppose
you embrace the dark side and to would
like to perform some attack like sequel
injection
here you put this command characters
after username and everything after that
will be ignored by server and this
equation 1 1 equals 1
always will return true so
identification will be passed anyway so
you can get any data from the database
using this simple trick why
psycho injection still so efficient and
popular it's so simple there are 20
tools that should protect database from
this type type of attack like intrusion
detection system web application
firewalls and so on but these tools
usually a rule based so it's just
learned these special characters this
signature and try to find this match in
queries in network data and for example
requests like that will be probably
blocked by by Web Application Firewall
because it's like no in combination of
symbols but there are plenty tools how
to bypass this kind of tools using
multiple command science mathematical
logical equation and so on so and there
is no way how to put everything in the
signatures so what can we do let's try
to apply machine learning to this task
as far as it's more to use more abstract
information about query than just sample
imagine and our approach can be
described like this big bigger and the
biggest first we consider this query as
a string and read some string analysis
we get some features out of these like
countable parameters how many parameters
actually in query how they're order then
we get like lexical parameters like
values fresh
sorry letters ratio digits rate ratio
and so on then we analyze keywords which
is special secure commands words like
select where from and so on and also we
count some punctuation symbols because
as you can see before it's really often
using for application so then we use
scikit-learn library to create the
models like SVM we'll try a swim and
play a bit with multi-layer perceptron
ok then can we do something else of
course we try back of words so we get
this feature we consider this query as
sentence and extract some words and
crane create the dictionary of unique
words in our query from our queries from
our data sets but using whole words
normal words like from from the normal
human dictionary were created to to
lankan to sparse feature vector that's
why we decide to keep only keywords and
reminding we split two character big
rounds as you can see here then we apply
two techniques to create vectors first
was count frequency which just called
how often this big Rama pier
or keyword appears on on query and ii
was tf-idf when we use also weights how
it's really important this particular
talking to our task and then we also
play with some machine learners
multi-layer perceptrons and get a model
like that and what next
okay of course try some sequel some
sequential model don't just count how
often this bigrams appear that also keep
the owner how it goes because it's
really can be important for us of course
we apply we use the same bigrams and
keywords vector and put it to embed and
there i don't think that it necessary to
explain how it works here because i
guess you heard about it a lot and we
tried to models too much more often used
models for for these tasks like LS TM
and GRU and play with hyper parameters
as well so the result was real surprised
surprising because we got almost 100% of
accuracy almost for all models and this
is result for validation test not for 14
and here the question the trade-off
between complexity and accuracy appears
because do we really need to destroy the
plan to get rid of sequel injection I
guess no if you have if you look at this
table more closely you can see that
simple multi-layer perceptron works 200
times faster than sequential model
that's why we apply this to our product
and it works like that okay now we are
ready to the next question the last
question how to fight that this
spaceship and let's look at the bigger
idea first everything start with an idea
or customer needs or business
requirements and after that we study
this problem what can we do actually and
we create our vision of this probe on
this problem
after that we round this data science
cycle with data collection data
transformation creating pipelines and
filtering and stuff like that
after that we create models and test
just hyper parameters and so on and
after the validation result will be good
we can deploy to product and give the
result achievement but it's not actually
the end because we need to monitor how
it really works in in big world in the
real world how it works means customer
data how it react on data change and so
on and this feedback allows us reduce
false positive fair rate get some better
results for performance and be more
sensitive to customer needs and now we
can summarize that we know something
more about how
how machine learning works in cyber
security field we know how to build
spaceship and how how to make it fly
thank you for your attention and now
your turn to ask a questions do you have
questions to our speaker ok no questions
so maybe you'll be able to catch respect
there's one ok sorry understood
something but how did you finally get
the data set or labeled both for
evaluation and for training that is
balanced and so on big enough to like
get the precise accuracy and so on on
the testing set
yeah probably missed this part thank you
for question well we did try a set of
penetration testing days let's say so we
create some laboratory let's say for
some victim application that we will
attack and we that we attacked and that
using different penetration testing
tools we get we was able to get some
data from it from log files actually and
after we had the idea how it actually
goes from this penetration testing tools
we were able to put it to generate data
generation generator and generate some
more samples so we was able to get about
six
thousand six hundred thousand samples
total that after that we splitted and
for test and validation three and said
of course okay so thanks so much
there's gonna be a coffee break so if
you want to talk to marina about
security and and other stuff regarding
their talk feel free
okay thanks a lot